so i've been studying for mako now for a
number of months and it's been one of
the most eye-opening experiences as a
musician as a group of ten
[Music]
no
think of it in
it's really changed how i understand
rhythm and form in particular
and if you stick around until later on
in the video you can hear a composition
that i recently wrote which infuses
elements of flamenco with my own style
in writing music
[Music]
for those of you who aren't familiar
with this genre flamenco is a form of
spanish music that involves voice
[Music]
instruments such as the acoustic guitar
percussion
and dance
[Applause]
when i'm writing music i'm constantly
looking for inspiration from other
musicians styles and genres to help me
consider new ideas to incorporate into
my music these include new concepts in
harmony pattern rhythmic elements a
general vibe or any other aspect of
music with flamenco i was really
influenced by the traditional way of
counting
unique ways of accenting
and the types of patterns i hear a lot
with acoustic guitar
in particular i took note of the extreme
level of virtuosity
rhythmic energy
[Music]
and the fast strumming patterns
so when i first started out on this
journey i got help from my friend jeremy
who was classmate of mine at junior
or like this
he's incredibly talented and versatile
[Music]
and since graduating he's been
freelancing in new york city while
learning all kinds of new genres
[Music]
one of them being flamenco
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so i asked him to give me a lesson on
some of the basics of flamenco and that
put me off to a great start the super
backbone of the solea
is
like that so there's two halves one
two
one two three
first half the what it's called is the
compass
that's another term the compass is
the compass it's also like think of like
the ruler the compass it's the same
thing it's the structure it's the
backbone so then there's two halves
solea
is only changing
you just changed
you just shift
now i guess the next thing is
and don't freak out
but they won't count like that
they count it one two one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten
so you click the end
no no no it's just what they call it it
would be it would be uh so it's about
accenting
no no no think of the numbers as sounds
how about that think of the numbers as
sounds not actual numbers okay so a lot
of this confused me in the beginning but
two things really helped me understand
this form of counting much better the
first was actually to count in spanish
rather than to count in english
stress
okay
[Music]
sort of
after getting used to it there was a
certain rhythm to the language itself
that
allowed for beats and accenting to feel
a little more natural to me these
numbers rhyme
one of those threes
a little bit not completely but they
rhyme enough to me
that make them stand out the second was
to start visualizing the rhythm with
what is commonly known as the flamenco
clock which instead of being linear is
circular
patrol
you substitute undo for 11 and 12.
[Applause]
so with this layout the basic dna of
flamenco rhythm involves emphases on 3
and ten and sometimes also six and eight
with this in place depending on where
you start and stop your cycles you can
accommodate the rhythmic changes of the
different styles within the genre so
this sort of reminds me of how modes
work in harmony say that we have c major
[Music]
all white keys starting on c
now instead of starting on c we start on
d
[Music]
still the same notes just in a different
order different starting point
it has a different sound now it's d
dorian
[Music]
if we start on e
[Music]
we have e phrygian
which is a commonly used mode in
flamenco so that's how i'm understanding
the different shifts in rhythm where you
have the same clock the same format with
the accents and the numbering but you
just shift around the starting point
so that it becomes a different form of
the original rhythm
the most important thing is to decide on
which beat of the clock you need to
begin so when using the flamenco clock
you don't shift the accents within the
12-bit pattern but at the beginning
as well as alegria
and related genres such as cantina
mira
romera and caracoles start on beat one
the buleria guajira petenera and
fandango de gueva start on beat twelve
the cigarilla and relayed genres such as
caballe libiana serrana and martinete
start on beat eight to me this is why i
was confused is because someone you know
if you look what is bulletin rhythm they
would say
then i would look at the videos and they
would go they would count in and then
they would go
like
what where's the beat oh there we go
like well that just sounds like it's in
like 6 8 or something you know like okay
what's that sometimes they would go like
this
[Music]
well well i don't get it but the song
says it's in valydia what's going on
it's still always happening and that's
how people get improvised there's like
these little gears that you can
choose from so much stuff happens these
crazy like
wild syncopations happen all these
offbeats
so like the guitar will do this too
before the romate like when it's really
getting like about to close or not like
that
they'll go check
you know it's like a little game for a
second and then it's like
you know and that's what makes it so
exciting because everybody's like
resolving at the same time
[Music]
now talking more about harmony i got
really familiar with firstly the
andalucian cadence
[Music]
and the phrygian mode
[Music]
[Applause]
in flamenco the harmony often shifts
away from the main key on the three
[Music]
so with these ingredients in mind i
started to write my piece for the mini
keyboard and throughout this process i
continued to listen to various flamenco
artists
[Music]
and i would improvise often using the
andelucian cadence and the phrygian mode
okay flamingo
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
by the way i really recommend checking
out david bruce's video on flamenco so
flamenco was born in this region of
spain known as andalucia because he goes
more in depth about the history and
origins of flamenco which is a crucial
part in understanding the nature of this
music listen to the listen how they
phrase it listen how they you know
because there is a swing too we didn't
talk about this i'll try and play as
robotic as possible okay all right
but now with a little more feeling the
swing so
i'm also playing accents which help but
i'm also
it's not quite even it's sort of
yeah if i was to grid it this is also
how i think of it which
um is helpful and not a lot of people
talk about it if i'm going
the rests are also swung the grid is
just
or something you know what i mean that's
how i think of it at least the grid
itself is the grid is different
the whole grid is different it's not
just that rhythm when it's being played
as swung the whole grid is wrong
that's not your favorite thing now
[Music]
i'm going for
e major
and then
f major
back to e major
[Music]
[Music]
so before i went out to record the piece
i went on to instagram and did a live
stream where i asked you all where i
should go film and i got a suggestion to
do it at a public library and so i did
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so like i said in the beginning of the
video i focus mostly on the overall
rhythmic qualities of flamenco and
that's because that's only how far i've
been able to get into this it's been
taking me a while
and plus i'm a little slow
but there are plenty more things to
learn about including what happens with
palmas which is the clapping
what happens with singing and dancing
which are actually
the most important parts
more in terms of harmony and rhythm i
understand there are some styles that
actually don't count in 12 but in four
and just more in general so hopefully i
can spend more time on that in the
future
if you haven't seen my other genre
exploring videos do check them out in
the playlist and let me know in the
comments which genres you think i should
explore in the future
one
yeah nice
are you awesome
you suck against yourself